welcome to [ __ ] back to some Manish
Jesus I don't really know what did you
wait I know exactly what to do
there's yes yes they're supposed to be a
key here there's no key here something
is missing something is wrong I'm super
sad face I don't know if I have to
replay this small or whatever
usually they're really buggy they're
supposed to be okay here
I swear I swear on my mother's penis
they're supposed to be a penis area I
mean I care so what I'm gonna do is
we're gonna play on the other mod it's
not a problem because I don't know I
just I don't think that holy [ __ ]
a momento has been added for your turn
what the [ __ ] was that sound that's big
I need one move and I found the bedroom
key I hope there is a virgin in there
waiting for me why I don't know
obviously sighs open open open
nope cause it yes I think we're done in
here I'm pretty freakin fast today I
need a key to unlock the door I would
assume it's this one why I would lock
myself in I do not know let's continue
pottery
excuse me pottery downstairs
sounds alright I mean it can't be that
bad let's head on downstairs I guess
this is door say anything County creepy
place actually
plates breakable plates my favorite kind
Oh cozy rainy mood don't mind if I do
why am I wasting my liner let's go here
I've been wanting there
let's go to the food storage
lots and lots of progress in [ __ ]
oh dude there's like mice
I wanna cuddle with you come here come
here hate my sister still alright jump
on the back okay whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa
dafuq you cannot die yet
it was the mice it's it's held on me
told on me
it's wheel well square do what I think I
know what's going on yes it's the same
like in the original story I suppose I
bet that's nice having to leave me a bed
at least maybe it's for the rave time
later I should just wait here and bend
over
no monster ready I'm ready
bending over he's obviously busy with
something else I mean how the hell could
you say no to my [ __ ]
he locked me in
I guess it's into that kind of stuff and
this I not even gonna ask him about I
need to find a way out there's a hole
here maybe I can drag it off no no I
can't even grab it that's what she said
hahaha oh man that was a good one
hello and I laughed too much at my own
jokes it's so awkward I have a box
oh dude who's over there anyway I would
just assume that we can fit this box in
ah drag drag crap doesn't work I thought
I was a genius we should move the bait
mm-hmm beautiful I thought it was a
genius you know what that how that will
end maybe over here
come on drag it really ah let's do it
with all the boxes
how the heck I'm doing this with my arms
I'm not gonna ask even maybe a numpty
mean doing it with my arms show me your
genitals
your generals what show me your genitals
your genitals yeah
I love that sound I probably don't do it
as well
but I'm least on man enough to admit it
hmm
berelson ship
ah come on Maris be friendly there we go
I just wanted an something that was
pretty emoji well well well what do we
have here
dinner snacks for later I like them
toasted
whoa whoa more more more more more MORE
I'd then into anything I didn't touch
anything
I'm just here barrels it was a barrels
look like what he's doing
look what they were doing wasn't me ask
why okay it's fine
sorry bells how do you need to bring you
there's a needle thingy leaving Lee
Haleh you don't
holy crap I'm a genius
skully yes no face the [ __ ] oh wait yes
face how do I rotate yeah I thought it
was see for sure yeah I did it for a
minute
I love reading I haven't missed you very
much now to get out of this castle stop
dropping me just
I'm sorry Scully stupid son of a [ __ ]
did you do this did you do this
look at me Scully I am sorry pity I have
cheated on you son of a [ __ ] I'm just
gonna leave him here for now no not the
poo buckets
seriously this position is pretty that
askable what were they thinking placing
him like this like what the hell oh that
was was I was doing earlier I'm glad I
didn't bend over for the monster holy
[ __ ]
well I guess we could move on it dungeon
haunts let's go I'm excited
dungeon
it's why all the cool kids are at it's
pretty [ __ ] dark let the lid off king
kelana COFF COFF Alana someone said that
I should do the opposite of what I get
because I always get the wrong one but I
forgot wait I have to redo it oh they do
lead off king kelana cough cough Alana
had done it all the doula daf I've done
pack up if possible do for and cliff so
I'll go this way
freaking baby squealing squealing I'm
not gonna say that it's - pervert
thank you thank you thank you all this
good all is well
thank you very much the game is so kind
to me what the heck is going on here
brooms what you never seen a broom
before I don't know spin around
not sure why I'm doing this but it
sounds pretty dramatic when I do it
don't mind me
spinning over here
well well well well well I have combined
a hammer with a chipper
look how fast I'm alluding holy crap
yeah yeah yeah let's play some oil in
this [ __ ] oh very nice cockroach
I just love saying cockroach because
then I have an excuse for saying [ __ ]
anyway
whoa it kind of creeped me out a little
bit
do you place your boots in between their
or your balls I guess either makes sense
I mean they both make sense obviously
and let's have her time yeah whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa go go go go go go go go
ah [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I
didn't uh barrel it was the barrels I
swear to god it was the barrels where
the [ __ ] is he I don't even sit oh man
he's look it's so sexy
I bet he's been working out look at that
ass he's got a key
love that friggin cracking noise I swear
to god it was apparels
ah crap I looked at him for too long I'm
going insane here
the heck is that ah acid
ah crap battle you blew my cover your
stupid traitor I'm pretty sure you can't
come in here though
oh come on I barely looked at you please
tell me you can't get in here haha you
sneaky devil holy take the potatoes I
don't even want them okay let's just not
look at him damn
are you oh he's looking at me of course
my ass I'm looking oh come on oh oh no
bad news bad news barrels
please [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] I'm [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] up part
just don't look at it don't look at what
am i doing what barrels diddy barrels do
something to you so sorry I'm just
hearing the corner
come on I'm so [ __ ]
[Applause]
I'm insane - [ __ ] raids pretty
[Music]